Now this is something you should be proud of.
It's hard to learn JavaScript, but it's even harder to learn it well.
Now you may still feel a little bit shaky around implementing things like this,
but that's completely normal.
So, I'm going to give you a few other ideas on how to
change your todo application.
Because although it's cliche' to say, practice does make perfect.
Here's some things that you can add to the todo application.
Let the user set the priority status when their creating the todo item.
Let users filter or sort by that same priority status.
Expand the priority status feature to have more than two levels.
Right now it's either priority or not priority.
What if there were different levels of priority?
Priority one, two and three?
What about adding a recycle bin for recovering deleted todos.
You could add colors, so that way people using your
application can associate different todos with each other by using colors.
You could add a whole labeling system for sorting and filtering.
And those are only the ideas that I came up with,
there are tons more things that you can do with this particular application.
Some of these are fairly trivial to implement, and
some of them are quite a bit more work.
And here's the best part,
if you make any of these changes or any others, they'll be your changes.
You will also be making whatever CSS changes are necessary, and
that is exciting.
You're finally at the point where you can do this stuff completely on your own.
So here's my challenge to you, try it.
If you're feeling hesitation or trepidation, go ahead and
change your attitude from, oh, I don't know if I can do that.
To, I know I can do that, my self.
It might just take me a little bit of time, or I might need to do some research.
And that right there, that change is the hardest part.
It's changing your mind, you're not grappling with the code, or
the technical problem.
You're grappling with yourself.
So, take your hesitation, throw it out the window, and do it.
Start on the project.
Start solving the problem.
Now here are two things that have worked for
me that I would like to share with you.
The first is to be a detective.
Remember that in the world of computer programming there is no magic at all.
So any code that you have and
any problems that you have, are discoverable and understandable.
You can go in and you can change things.
You can change the way they work, and you can fix them.
So remember that, there's no magic.
The second thing is, I'd like you to write code everyday.
That's a challenge.
John Resig, the original author of jQuery wrote,
the feeling of making progress is just as important as making actual progress.
So, I'd like you to add this to your calendar, every single day
make yourself a notification, or a reminder, to write some code.
So congratulations.
You've made it through this course.
But don't let it stop here.
Keep the momentum up, keep building things and reading, and
learning, and exploring.
And as you build cool things, go ahead and share them on the Udacity Forum,
because it's always good for other students to see what you've been building,
for you to see what they've been building,
and we always love seeing what you guys built.
Keep it up, good work, and have fun.
We'll see you later.